Now, a router in AS1 might learn two routes to a destination, one via the AS
path 24 and the other via the AS path 34. Local preference or simply local pref
allows an operator to configure the router to
assign different preference values to each of the
routes that it learns. The default local preference
value Is 100. If the operator prefers that this
router select the path through AS two, it can configure the router to set a
higher local preference for that route. Such
as 110. This results in this router selecting
the route through AS two and sending traffic to the destination in AS four via
AS two. In this way a operator can
adjust local preference value of incoming route to
control put bound traffic or to control
how traffic leaves it tominac system in route
to a destination this is extremely useful in
configuring primary and back up routes for example
here the route though A.S two might
be the primary route,and the route through AS
three, is the backup route. Now typically as
I mentioned, local preference is used to control
outbound traffic. But sometimes autonomous systems can
attach what's called a BGP community to a
route to effect how a neighboring autonmous system
sets local preference. A community is nothing more,
but a fancy jargon word for a tag on a route. So let's suppose that AS four
wanted to control inbound traffic by affecting how AS two or AS three set
local preference. In this case, let's suppose, that AS two wanted traffic
to arrive via AS three, its primary, rather than by AS two, its backup. In this
case, AS two might advertise its BGP routes with primary and backup communities.
The backup community value might cause a router in AS two to adjust its local
preference value, thus affecting how AS two's
outbound traffic choices are made. So, again
local preference is used to control outbound
traffic, in this case AS two's outbound traffic
decision, but the use of a BGP
community on the route advertisement can sometimes
be used to cause a neighboring AS
to make different choices regarding it's outbound traffic.
Thereby, allowing an AS to specify a primary or back up
path for incoming traffic. This type of arrangement requires prior agreement.